in the Great Hall of the Democratic  Party there are assembled the world's  greatest Democratic heroes created from  the establishment elite party leaders  fundraisers lobbyists and Jimmy Carter  with 700 more Super Friends able to  choose whichever candidate they want as  the party's presidential nominee  regardless of what primary voters  actually want their mission to fight  grassroots candidates that might  actually represent the party's base to  right that which is wrong according to  privileged insiders and to serve all  mankind no okay nope just Hillary just  just Hillary Clinton the super-delegates